for the past 10 years all of my
confidence all of my self-worth all of
who i am
i have gotten from the love and approval
of strangers and it's been brilliant for
the past 10 years
it's a very strong scaffolding life upon
for as long as it's still there if you
imagine my life is
my personality
for it's intensely for like the past 18
months and then i was just
daniel dan all right and how the [ __ ]
down
ladies and gentlemen welcome back i'm
joined by daniel sloss
yeah there's no audience to clap oh
there hasn't been there's no audience
anywhere no that is not
how is it being a comedian during a
pandemic tell me about it
um i mean it wasn't it's fine now it's
good now like i'm
it's uh some gigs are slowly starting to
breed back over the past a month and a
half
i've had probably about close to 20 gigs
and it's those have been really nice
because
even though it's much much smaller
crowds than
been used to especially in the past two
years uh
it feels like being four or five years
into comedy again
like it's you know how there's some
people out there who were like oh i'd
never go back to high school and there's
other people but like i'd love to go
back to high school with the knowledge i
have now
it's kind of like that man like i get to
go you know smaller audiences ones that
you know that i would used to play into
seven or eight years ago but now i just
get to play to them with this
i don't know this wealth of experience
that i have it's and it's it's fun i'm
sort of relearning bits of stand up as
well and relearning skills that i
haven't had to use for years and and
i'd say that's been positive but it's
taken
six [ __ ] months to get there do you
feel out of sorts do you feel like you
had the
sort of the off-season yips when you got
back into it um
oh a little bit like there was it was
the first time i did it it was the first
time a long time that i'd been
nervous eh why were you nervous
because because i've i lost all of my
self-worth during [ __ ] locked down
you know
suddenly going you know i've had i've
had a very very good career
um but especially in the past two years
has been
immensely and yeah intense man netflix
came out you go from playing 400 rooms
to 3 000 rooms and
it's an 18-month tour that takes you
know 300 shows and
you know it's all very very exciting and
and for the past
10 years all of my confidence all of my
self-worth all of who i am
i have gotten from the love and approval
of strangers and it's been brilliant for
the past 10 years
it's been absolutely brilliant it's a
very strong scaffolding to really life
upon
for as long as it's still there for as
long as it's still there so
if you imagine my life as a my
personality and who i am the human being
is a [ __ ] change
20 someone's just coming at the very
bottom i took all three and went do you
need these
no and uh the power [ __ ]
but obviously and that's what i
desperately tried to do was to try and
prop
the [ __ ] tower back up what did you
prop it up with uh
just i mean for the first two months
uh it was back because because i've been
so desperate from time off for so long
i saw you i think two days after you got
back
we went for lunch in edinburgh yeah and
that was like the middle of march it was
two days before
lockdown came in um sorry before
americans weren't allowed to go back to
america and i remember because the chick
that i was with in edinburgh
had left me at 4am yes and i'm like is
this actually just all the big no no no
no no
i'm sure i'm sure that that was what the
truth was yeah and so i've seen you and
you were like
like this is lovely but still even then
only two days after you'd finished
in the back of your head you had this
australia tour and the book which we're
gonna get into
um and even then you were already kind
of putting yourself into that
well cause i've always got that so like
whenever i've had time off
it's always been like i've got this next
month off and i know after that i'm on
tour for another six weeks someone two
for another six months so it's
i was really good at cramming my time
off like i would be like right over the
next month i'm doing [ __ ] all
i'm sitting in a bin bag i'm playing
xbox all day and i'm smoking weed
every second of the video of my
existence because i've learned this i
work for those months
this is my time off i've got this job
coming up then
and whereas this didn't feel like time
off this felt like [ __ ]
unemployment like it fell
like just suddenly like the in a time
when like
the people were throwing words around
key workers and like crucial workers and
you're like
[ __ ] i'm so pointless to the world
there's no
like pointless work is that like again
and it says it's comedians it's the last
one you go [ __ ] we're dead we're not
needed right now
and there's and yeah and i was just i
couldn't
i couldn't handle the time off because
it just
it just had a nagging voice in the back
of my head going this isn't time off
you're not doing anything like this
isn't
you know that it isn't a tour in two
months that you're gonna get money from
there isn't a [ __ ]
you know uh a show that you need to be
working on because there's no audience
and uh it took me a while to sort of
realize what was going on because i was
just
mad eh smoking weed living my life
bothering my poor girlfriend
just like [ __ ] tapping her on the
shoulder being like hey hey fill the
[ __ ] void
i need you to love me as much as 2000
strangers do on a regular basis
you're busy sorry i'll go
like kind of glad it happened because i
had to
i had to really look long and hard in
the [ __ ] mirror because i've been
i've been daniel sloths for
it's intensely for like the past 18
months and then i was just
daniel dan all right and how the [ __ ]
down yeah i've not met him since he was
a 17 year old who was just [ __ ]
you know insecure in high school who was
starting to do stand up as a hobby and
there was only like the slight hopes in
the back of his head that he might be
able to make money out of it
one day and uh [ __ ] he doesn't have any
hobbies
he's a boring guy so i didn't have
because my life was so intensely stand
up all the time like i didn't need
hobbies i wasn't even writing going out
to do things to find material for the
next show because the next show wasn't
going to happen at any point soon yeah
and normally i just gotta go to the next
city i get to meet people i drink i do
drugs i [ __ ] party i live the life
and that's you know
and then suddenly i'm just in my house
just going [ __ ]
what do i do i don't have any interests
like i thought that my only hobby was
marijuana
but what was really nice i did start
discovering like uh
not parts of myself that i'd sort of
suppressed but it's part of myself
that i don't know when i was a teenager
i wasn't confident enough to
to enjoy them but like [ __ ] dnd man
you really oh god online or matt oliver
i'm the bit i love nerd [ __ ]
the the flavor was today i spent in the
[ __ ] games uh
like a board game shop just [ __ ]
reading notebooks surrounded by notes
and i was like this is where i belong
i'm with my people with my [ __ ]
people people that i deny these mouth
breathing neck bearded in cells over
here
yeah well but i because i've been no man
there's nerds in the past
they're so you know so i just ended up
talking to the owner of the place just
about uh
comic books and stuff for a bit so i got
to do
i don't know i got to i got to start
dming sessions i am a dungeon master
so i got to do okay
like archaeology on the old me and being
like i wonder if this still fits my
personality
like this thing i enjoyed when i was 17
still fit in there
apparently it is some of it's still
there and it's my it's been good
thanks to i mean thanks to [ __ ]
therapy and meditation and whatnot it's
been a lot easier now i'm
infinitely with it i'm glad we didn't do
this anyway four months ago yeah were
you crying weeping mess in the corner
do you think that if it wasn't for the
fact that you're talented
and have been blessed with some like
semi-okay good looks that you would
really really struggle in life because
dungeons and dragons
the wii like you have the makings of a
really
like successful incel but you've managed
to like get past that oh i think i would
have
man had i not discovered comedy i would
have i would absolutely
been a [ __ ] uh right-wing internet
[ __ ] troll
from the bottom i truly [ __ ] had i
not discovered comedy i would have been
one of the
i would have been a [ __ ] proud boy
man you've been giving me gifts yeah
if i hadn't like got into comedy like
him
and had this world where i just got to
meet so many different people from so
many
you know different backgrounds and get
to travel the world and experience
things
uh i would have absolutely been one of
them you know
you know it's hard being a white man
like that would have been me
because i would have nothing else to put
it into i would have just been
because i was quite an angry teenager
and then i mean i've still got some
anger within me
we all do but you know i got to i got to
put that angle in to stand up i could
have put it into the performance all the
all this stuff i had there was an outlet
for it and thank god because if it
hadn't been it would have just been
i would have shot up a school man it's
um
it's interesting that people who don't
have that outlet and don't find
something in life i think struggle
with like their internal monologue and
one of the
interesting comments douglas murray made
on a show that i did with him recently
was he's adamant that the people who
have the most
extreme views on the left and the right
have never traveled
so it's because as soon as you travel
and you start to meet people from
different cultures
yeah you realize like they're actually
really fun i wanted no job like a
japanese person like they're [ __ ]
sick
and like yeah chinese government
probably needs a bit of work but like
you meet some people from china from
china and you're like [ __ ] like this is
awesome and you're what you
i mean when you get to travel you see
the humanity that is so common across
the world you go here's all these people
uh you know they're so different to who
i am
and then you just see a mom yelling at a
child and you go oh that's how my mom
yelled at me ah we're all the same we
are
literally we're all the same [ __ ]
species we were just born in different
parts
and yeah i think it's i i think it's
such a
such important thing to travel but such
an unfortunate thing but it's you know
it's something that you had that money
to do
imagine imagine if you'd not had this
kind of like weird sabbatical break
from doing your comedy and perhaps you
further
layered more and more and more and more
life and ego
have you considered this the fact that
the the um stools being turned upside
down a little bit and you're balancing
it on one leg
and then start you know do you remember
tom and jerry and when
they'd like the fridge would be balanced
on top of a fork upside down
on the floor and then yeah yeah yeah and
that's kind of
what would have happened had it have
been 40 year old daniel 50 year old
daniel like coming at the end of his
career and then being like
17 year old daniel's still in here by
the way [ __ ] all right
well the eagle would have become i mean
catastrophic yes
and and and i say that as somebody whose
ego two years ago would have been
described by some of my friends his
catastrophe you know a lot of the
elegant things
uh i used to say it still sometimes say
like a lot of the time i go oh my
my tongue is firmly in my cheek and upon
further reflection now
it [ __ ] wasn't i was just uh it was
this sort of disguise of
hey if i if i if i acknowledge how
arrogant i am
that i'm going to try and pass that off
as self-awareness and irony
because even last year i remember part
of the show that you were doing that you
were touring on quite heavily was
breaking the fourth wall about this way
that you are with yourself like my
charisma is built around
this thing so it's you are right it's a
level of self-awareness but it's also
only like about that thick it's a veneer
that allows you to
make a proxy for like self-awareness but
you're right without doing the real work
it's like when people do ironic racism
you go
hi but you even though you're doing it
ironically you still want to say those
things
like that's not you don't maybe say them
with malice or hate it or whatever but
there's still a deep
it comes from the next written and and
fearful [ __ ] place
it's the same as the the people who are
the most vehemently anti-gay
they're the ones who are the most
aroused when you put them in an mri
and work play gay pawn in front of them
who can't switch off the arousal but
like the lady doth protest too much
all right sort of keep ahead how much
have you been able to create content
then is it pandemic like a gold mine for
content or is it quite difficult to turn
corvid 19 into something funny
it's been real i have the worst internet
connection in the world i live in a part
of edinburgh which for some reason
it's just people there's my download
speed is
uh seven megabits per second and marble
speeds points
point two you can't do anything i can't
do anything and then over and then the
pandemic
and that all goes down so i really
wanted to get into i've got
so many friends that are really good at
like streaming on twitch
and it's and it seems to be like
a good it's it just seemed like it's
something fun to do during the month i
don't go a lot
i love playing a beer games like people
enjoy watching me talk for whatever
[ __ ] reason like i
start doing a thing on instagram live
which was just day drinking with dan
because i was day drinking anyway
and people were like what are you up to
and i was like this so i just said and
get drunk during the day on instagram
live and it's one of the weird things
that happens in this [ __ ] life but
like
i think the average viewership while it
was live was about 1200 people
but and then we get like 50 000 views
all together you go why are people
watching you get pissed but they
i'm blessed that people care yeah and
enjoy for some reason
me ranting about things that i'm
semi-passionate about but then
pretending to be really enraged by the
people enjoy watching and i felt like i
could do that on twitch but i just don't
have this [ __ ] internet connection
it's finally happening now
i've er i have to i promise you i have
the most
and i'll tell you off camera i have the
most expensive internet connection
in the uk available uh
and it's still not in yet but i hope to
it just which seems so interesting to me
because it's i think
everyone only really knows it as this
sort of gaming platform but having
watched what people like
like lemmy's able to do on it and people
are doing different
sort of shows on it cooking shows it's
just a
new platform and i think in the next
year or two one comedian is going to do
one thing on twitch
and the rest of us are going to go ow
there we go that's it that's the one and
the good thing about twitch is
it's a direct relationship between you
and your audience you don't have anyone
from the bbc who hasn't stepped foot in
a comedy club in the past seven years
being like hey hey hey
we know you're great and we know you've
got all these fans but let us tell you
what we think
do i watch comedy no no i don't am i the
head of com yes i am that's me
yeah yeah um and i'm desperate for any
world but i don't have to work with a
[ __ ] bbc or any [ __ ] like that again
so twitch seems to be there
i had a uh we had a porn star right
where you were
not long ago um sienna and she was
talking about she's been in the game for
a little while maybe like eight years
and she was talking about the transition
from the like typical porn model working
for brothers or fake taxi or whoever it
might be
um and like getting paid like okay but
not they don't get
mental money compared with how much they
make and then only fans came along and
then miami.vip came along
and they were able to have direct
creator to fan
like interaction the ability to get
tipped and
and make money and she has decentralized
and taken complete ownership of her own
earning potential and now she uses
browsers and
fake taxi as the front end of her funnel
to be like
i know this will get four million plays
on pornhub then
some percentage of those people will
find me then some percentage of those
people will join my only fans
and now she's making like 10 grand a
week
doing what she was doing in any case but
doesn't have to leave a house how to
like renovate a room into like this
there's probably glitter everywhere you
know and like feather bows around i
imagine and lots of rubber things
but like other than that she's now
completely in control and it seems a
little bit like
every different industry is trying to
find its
niche for that like even esports has
gone from
it being esports getting paid by perhaps
winnings and competitions to now twitch
decentralized you to
consumer and it seems like comedians
perhaps might go the same way well i
mean plenty of comedians are there's
some comedians who are really really
good at well i've already said lemmy
he's uh
he's i watch his twitch all the time
he's so good in it ian sterling's on a
twitch as well get gareth ward does uh
um he just he plays scary games in the
dark because he's
one of the biggest in the world and it's
great it's great to watch somebody who
hates
skating games play skinny games and you
get to scare them during it as well you
can like
switch through so many of these
interactions things that i'm supposed to
do so you can send in like a ghost or
whatever to go and see
no no wait because he weighs because you
could so if you bed like 500 he has to
play it in the dark with the headphones
on
and then you can use bits to just shriek
in his ear
randomly so it'll just be a bit intense
and you can just yeah
but it's that it's that sort of it's mad
it's the funniest thing
he shits his pants all the time and he
gets so
visibly angry
um it's uh it's it's so fun to watch and
uh
yeah i'm really inspired watching people
like uh
like garden and let me do these things
with fact there is that you know don't
be wrong
i love stand up and stand up of whatever
form it exists and i will always do it
that is my
it's what i was put on this earth if i
could do but
if i could earn money from playing
computer games and being a dick i'm
going to do that as well
why didn't you decide to do zoom comedy
shows there was talk like at the
beginning of the year
that's not my [ __ ] job but you could
have
i don't know stayed in contact with fans
remain like earned a bit of money i
don't know i don't know i do i've got a
real issue
with taking money off my fans
like the fact that i've cons it's one of
the very few things that uh
me and my agent back heads over is
ticket prices and stuff i think comedy
should be affordable at all times
um i if any comedian that charges
[ __ ] over a hundred quid a ticket i
understand why you're doing it but i
think it's dishonest
like you don't get to go on stage and
[ __ ]
pretend to be in every man and try and
relate to these people when
you know you're going give me give me
two weeks worth of your [ __ ] money
and and i've always had a problem it's
the same reason i don't sell march
because to me i know i need to get past
it but
to me it just feels like why am i taking
you've already given me some of your
money like i don't want to
i want to take anything more for you i'm
just like i'm doing well already
yes i've got real um yeah just guilt
when it comes to that [ __ ]
um whereas and also
i'll i'm in charge of my [ __ ] life my
fans do not get to dictate
a single part of what i create what i do
and that's how it works
it's a i you know i don't
i create shows that i want to do i
create things i want to do make people
laugh but
occasionally people like you know had
all this time off people like why
haven't you done your [ __ ] podcast
i'm sorry can't what do i [ __ ] owe
you
what do i owe you beyond nothing i owe
you nothing
um i'm about to drop a name here
um but it's david swimmer uh
um he uh after the golden contact after
my netflix specials came out because
he's a massive comedy fan and
i was doing a show in l.a and it was my
first show since
having been on netflix and it was like
the improv and it was
you know there was a real buzz when i
went on stage and i was trying to hang
out with him afterwards and
i just kept going off and people like i
get [ __ ] i get phone i was like yeah
yeah of course because i want to [ __ ]
please everyone and i'm so
grateful for this that i'm just i wanted
to just hang out with [ __ ] dave
and drink with them talk to him and
stuff but i keep getting pulled away and
i keep saying yes
and uh eventually two people finally
recognized him and they were like we got
a photo and he was like yeah no
and they were sort of taken aback and he
just kept out to me and
and they went can we and he was like no
i appreciate that you're a fan of my
workout
i'm very very grateful but no i'm
talking to my friend
spending time with my friend and i was
like how the [ __ ] did you do that and
he was like he was like man i'm so
obviously grateful but i don't owe
my [ __ ] i don't owe them anything beyond
what i create beyond what i do like it's
fans are amazing and it's brilliant to
have them but
the second that you feel you owe them
something
then the relationship changes and then
you resent them and he's like and i
don't want to resent people that
love me like that's not a nice healthy
village do you think that that is a
little bit of a manifestation again of
what you said about perhaps that
um feelings of self-worth coming through
like i need to continue to please these
people a little bit
like i'm not sure if i'm worthy of their
support therefore like i need to
the person who doesn't love the
girlfriend anymore but is terrified of
breaking up with her because deep down
he's not sure if he's
if he's worthy i don't know how it
manifests for you maybe
maybe and i think also like uh like i
i'm yeah i'm so desperate to please
people that if i give them the chance to
ask me for something i know i'll do it
so so i don't want to give my fans the
ability to ask for something
because i don't want to feel obligated
to them because i will don't start an
only fancy
whale but i've got such a lovely [ __ ]
um did people get sad when they found
out that you got a girlfriend that the
army of singletons that you created with
jigsaw did they feel like
their leader had betrayed them uh some
of the ones that didn't pay attention to
a word of the show did yes absolutely
but my
you know people who man i i like
the reason i also i don't go into my dms
on instagram that much is because
my jigsaw and dark re and x as well
really [ __ ] resonate with some people
like to a point where it's it's kind of
cultish and not in a bad way but just
i'd never considered how much you know
material would impact people's
lives and stuff and there's a level of
responsibility
and fear that i have there um that i'd
just rather avoid
why why do you not want to see what they
people say uh
because i'll feel responsible for them
like i've been jigs off
when netflix started first started
coming out i was in my instagram my dms
all the time because it was a new level
of attention people were telling me they
[ __ ] love me and then
you start responding and then you start
speaking to people who go through really
are going through really really hard
times you you know
some of my fans are suicidal and and
they start telling me about that and i'm
suddenly of course i'm conversating with
these people because i don't want them
to [ __ ]
kill themselves and but that was when my
agent was like
you've got to step away you're bad from
the dm involvement yeah you can't
um so with the the there's i've
definitely noticed when i don't post
about my girlfriend much on uh online
and that's
not because i'm ashamed of her it's just
because she's [ __ ] hideous
no um because i
i agreed to this life i signed the deal
with the devil
for the for the life of fame and success
and if she wants to sign that contract
herself she's allowed to sign that
contract herself but just because she's
my girlfriend doesn't mean she's she
automatically um
should be in the world but when i do
talk about it online so you get some
[ __ ] stupid people in the comments
like oh my god what about jigsaw i'm
like if you actually watch the show
the whole point of it is i absolutely
believe in love i've always [ __ ]
believed in love my parents have been
together for 35 years there's no
divorces i don't know about
i know love is real and it does exist i
just get i was always annoyed and i
still get annoyed by fake [ __ ] love
the emulations of love the [ __ ] cat
that
you know has been cut with other things
obligation and responsibility and fear
of loneliness it's not pure it's just
shy [ __ ] messy love
and uh yeah and i and i still [ __ ]
rail against that
but um for me now man this is
i'm probably in love like i would not
have gone through
this uh lockdown if it hadn't been for
you know my girlfriend she really um
i don't know she just made she made me
confident and you know
in the bits of me that i was never
confident in before so most people are
very very happy because they can see
that you know she makes me happy and
stuff
and then um also a man i couldn't get a
[ __ ] what people say i'm like like from
the bottom of my heart like if anyone
tweets or
it describes me anything negative i
don't reply because i find it
the equivalent of saying no you to a
dog's fart
like it's so unimpactful how do you how
do you deal with
sort of vitriol and hate and criticism
and stuff online by knowing i'm [ __ ]
better than every one of them
why would why would i give a [ __ ] wet
hot [ __ ]
about what some sad [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
dark and roomed
smashed his [ __ ] cheesy [ __ ]
fingertips into
on me [ __ ] off like [ __ ] what
world in what world would that opinion
ever affect me who the [ __ ] are you
to affect my opinion of myself [ __ ] off
get [ __ ]
you only get to see what i'll let you
[ __ ] see what i let you pay me to
[ __ ] see
[ __ ] oh there's the old me he's still
in he's like no you still got it
i know but i don't like that i don't
like that side of myself
it's horrible you've got to turn it on
and turn it off you know what was it
that you said when we were out
we were out for lunch and someone had
done something similar criticized you
about something and you said
who the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] my house has
got two kitchens
[Laughter]
you know that's the bits that always
come up in you know
therapy i'm like [ __ ]
where's this darkness come from what's
that about yeah it's the second kitchen
that's where it is that's where it looks
because you you moved your girlfriend in
yes the the tactical implication of that
was that you thought you were gonna have
an empty house that she would keep clean
yes no no that's just a horrible joke i
said on stage no
no my girlfriend moved to the january
because i love her dearly
but it was quite a good decision given
the foreseeable
yes i was didn't know about i was going
to be on tour
for ages so it was sort of like i moved
into the house and
um my my i bought the house wouldn't
mind
for it to be a family house i was like i
walked and i was like oh this is the
house that i'll raise my children in
um so we moved in and we knew i was
gonna be away a lot
um uh which we were used to but it was
good it was gonna be so much less than
the previous year so that was exciting
and then uh we were so worried as well
because she's
she's got a real job and stuff so like
even when i was home she would have her
nine to five we used to have this really
[ __ ] funny routine in
january which was i'd wake up every
morning and i'd make her a pack lunch
for her to go to work because i was home
and i'd never been home before and i
just got to
you're a cat man i well no no no people
who you've changed i go no no
this i've seen my father i know my this
is
this has always been inside of me like
the you know
the the romantic side of me the the kind
general side i just [ __ ] put down for
years and years because it wasn't funny
on stage
and then uh it's been allowed to
flourish a little bit more ah so your
house husbanding in it for a little
while yeah
punches and hoovering and i'd love to
man it's good [ __ ] life i'd love to
be a house [ __ ] like if in the [ __ ]
future if you want to say because she
she
really likes her job and i'd love to be
a [ __ ] stay-at-home dad
well i've not done that to any pain
being like it's not easy i know
bigger pain isn't [ __ ] easy but i
realized the challenge of it like
i'd like that yeah i can't wait to be a
dad man yeah
there's something something interesting
about being
sort of around about 30 is a man someone
talks about
like it's a such a trope to talk about
women have turned 30
and she's still single you know sort of
the biological clock state and you're
like oh [ __ ] element like how old's
that joke
but there is an equivalent for men i
find myself not doting because that's
too much
but children used to be disgusting and i
wanted to throw things at them
and now i'm not completely repulsed oh
see no i
so we've gone as you've i think there's
a scale that you slide up and down i'm
lagging behind you a little am i oh
i've always loved kids okay so but but i
think we've increased
careful what you say i've always looked
yeah man the amount
this is generally something that
constantly comes up in my stand-up er
because
in the show x i was talking i had a
routine about how much i love kids
unfortunately i also pepper all of my
sentences with the word [ __ ]
so there was several several times on
tour where i without just not because
i'm thinking about the next joke thing
about a number of other things
instead of saying i [ __ ] love kids i
tell my [ __ ] kids
and and some days some days i'd catch it
but i know there were other days days i
didn't
there were other days we just mentioned
i'd be like look i love [ __ ] kids man
because for me it's like it's it's it's
not i'm not using the word
[ __ ] as a verb it's a it's an ad it's
garnish isn't it yeah
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] that [ __ ] off
you know it's yeah yeah man there is
something
there's something interesting and
there's not an archetype for that and i
think that
like men probably could do with speaking
about that a little bit more the fact
that
you do you can desire a family and it's
still masculine to want that even though
you haven't
got about anything more and also why
does it have to be [ __ ] masked about
and again i say this is somebody who
deals with
his own toxic masculinity regularly you
all saw it come out about 15 minutes ago
and but i don't know i i don't
i don't i've never with toxic
masculinity i've never
understood the the bit of it that's
that men can't feel love or shouldn't
feel love i don't
i don't believe that i don't believe
that [ __ ] trope at all like my dad
adores his [ __ ] family even though
i've not seen my i've never seen my dad
cry
much he wasn't necessarily hiding from
me but
you've never you know my dad my dad
never struggled to sale of you would
never it wasn't difficult for him like
men can still
very much be like i love you that's a
[ __ ] man yeah yeah and if
and if being a strong man is important
to you which is to some men and i don't
think that's something we should
admonish it's nice to feel strong
sometimes it's it's a
good sort of thing it's just when if
when your ability to appear strong
doesn't allow you those moments of
weakness or
softness or that's when it's back but
this general idea of i want to be big
and strong
i want to be a protector okay just as
long as as long as you're happy and
sensible with it
for me it absolutely fits in with uh
i want to be a dad i want to protect my
family i want to [ __ ]
raise them to be good men that's uh you
know my granddad was always
about to make sure that is sound good be
a good man you get those generations
that they're like it's all about being
good is that a scottish thing hey nobody
looks sorry
i'm i mean maybe there's a lot of [ __ ]
down here so maybe
yeah you are right it's um i don't know
i think it's really interesting the
sort of where men are at at the moment
there seems to be
a lot of different kind of roots peeling
off you'll have heard of mgtow men going
their own way
which is basically it's like imagine
militant feminism
and then flip it completely opposite so
it's men saying we don't need women
um basically the only way to win the
game is not to play is what they think
so it's men who perhaps have been
scorned by women who are
um just don't really like the dynamic
that's going on
some divorcees some men have never had
partners or never had families
and um you've got that going one way and
then me and you talking about like i
can't wait to be a dad
i'm really excited to have kids i think
i'm going to be hopefully going to be a
good a good father
you know i don't know
it i see both sides of it because i see
how
hurtful relationship breakups can be and
so do you and for some people they would
rather than
deal with the risk of that occurring
again
yeah would just say no but that's not
about but yeah but i don't believe
that's what they're doing what they're
doing is
is is they're compressing their feelings
into to the point where it's becoming
carbon and coal in their bodies and
they're using that
fuel to burn hatred whereas
you know if you if you didn't [ __ ]
compress it with inside of you
you wouldn't be filled with this fuel of
[ __ ] anger
therapy man therapy is the tits and it
said i
think it's an absolute [ __ ] disgrace
that it's uh
it's something it's a form of privilege
that like i can afford to go to therapy
and and there are obviously free forms
of uh therapy
that people can go to but they're
difficult to get it's not available to
everyone it's not readily [ __ ]
available
and um i just don't think it's
especially this [ __ ] you man
like everyone needs therapy therapy
isn't affects to anything
the way i describe it therapy is just
putting a condom on the deck of 2020
before it [ __ ] you in the ass
like it's not it doesn't get rid of the
debt you're still gonna get [ __ ] in
the ass but god it stops some of the
diseases getting in
it's a bit smoother like it's a process
like it's not effects meditation isn't
the thick stuff
that it's all a process man you just
give yourself these
tools so that when you're going through
good times give yourself all the tools
and all the knowledge that when things
do get harder that you're able to
you know if you're one of these people
that is so bad at asking for [ __ ]
help give yourself the tools so the next
time
you don't have and also just ask for
help you stupid [ __ ]
what's it been psychotherapy um no i
just uh
so what happened was after the after my
tour last year i
lost a lot of myself i was very just
overworked overworked i just snapped i
didn't like who i was didn't like how i
was uh
i didn't like i was i was treating my
agent i didn't like how i was speaking
to people
and didn't like how short tempered it
was um so i just
literally emailed the thing and i was
just like hello and i just like
i [ __ ] don't like who i am i'd like
to start going to therapy
and uh they email back and they're like
this we recommend you go with and
ever since then just once a week and the
first couple ones is
like if you're a psychopath like i am
sure you're playing chess against a man
trying to help you
like like i'm literally i'm literally
paying you what do you want
yeah what do you want hi how are we
yeah can i win yeah i'm paying i'm
paying this man i'm like oh
it's just been a it's been nice to
because there's not that i don't have a
support and network and you know you
don't go to therapy
just because you don't have anyone to
talk to like i've i've got family that
loves me deeply i've got a very loving
relationship i've got
friends i can phone you anytime award we
could talk about things but that's not
what therapy is therapy is
somebody on the outside somebody
unbiased somebody who
is gonna like listen and help and just
recognize
your patterns of thoughts and and sort
of go hey hey you say this a lot but
that's
not true like i didn't realize i had
anxiety uh
with my therapist what type he's like
how's your anxiety i'm like
what anxiety more anxiety like they're
not allowed to roll their eyes but he
did
how do you feel when anyone's late to
something i'm like they should die they
should be drunk
in 2020 there's not a single reason to
be [ __ ] led to anything everything
tells you how long it takes to get
somewhere there's clocks in every
[ __ ] screen
to be late in 2020 is a willful decision
and he goes how do you feel when you're
late for things i'm like i would never
be late for anything because it would be
a [ __ ] disgrace and if i do
he's like that's anxiety oh
right and when i realized that's just
that small little realization of
like okay here's a here's a moment in
your life where your brain shot itself
right when it just had a [ __ ] whitey
internally i had a [ __ ] whitey
you then reflect back on other things
and go oh
i wasn't right in that moment or the
reason i freaked out then was because of
this for one of the big things i
discovered through
um meditation as well as uh therapy and
i don't know how whether this is
shocking news to other people whether
it's just me
i didn't realize that it wasn't my own
thoughts
right so for so long because all my
thoughts in my head have always been
so good and positive i've always
believed in them
for the past 12 years my brother would
be like slush you're the [ __ ] best
and i feel like god
i am the best i'd go on stage an
audience would confirm it
i'd be like [ __ ] thanks brian yeah
you're right i'm the bet i'm so [ __ ]
good
but my baby tell me all these positive
things and because my life was going
well i believed this internal monologue
i fully related
and then when lockdown hit my brain was
like you're [ __ ] worthless and
pointless
i was like well that must be true too
that must be
it's been right for the past 12 years
why would it not be right now
so my brain's going you're worthless but
i'm [ __ ] sad and be like [ __ ] you
are nailing it again
you are spawn with all of these
assessments the fact you know me so well
and then suddenly i'm like why am i
wallowing why am i sad
oh it's these it's it's
some of your thoughts are good and a lot
of them are and some of them are neither
good nor bad they're just weird thoughts
that you
relate to yourself and therapy for me
has just been helping me realizing
the occasional moments where my brain
i'm just like oh shut the [ __ ] up you
stupid cat not now
it's nice i like and i thoroughly
recommend it to
uh people who can get it but it's also
it's really i'd love to at some point in
the future do
it would be a dream of mine to get it
[ __ ] free everywhere to get on the
nhs
properly that'd be so good but we're
about to hit
national mental health week i think
that's two weeks time something like
that in the uk
yeah and um i agree i think after this
year we need more than a week
it needs to be national mental health
yeah um i don't know i think
definitely therapy the stigma around
that could do with being fixed
a lot like the fact that to say that
you're going to therapy
most people take that as an implication
that there's something
wrong with you yeah no i can just be
better i'm
functioning i mean i haven't walked out
into open traffic i'm not screaming
racist slurs on street corners like i
haven't shot myself
also there was something wrong with me i
didn't like myself yes and then if you
don't like yourself
that is something wrong with you you
should like yourself you should love who
you are you know does it and just
because you like who you are nothing why
does it mean
you're [ __ ] perfect and you know i
need a [ __ ] improvement but if you
don't like yourself
you're wrong that's a problem get that
get that sorted new book what's
happening with the book
uh it has been uh delayed because of
this and
because it's because it's being released
in america first
uh because it's american book um we want
to make sure that we could
uh do a book tour with it like go out
and how do you do a book tour as a
comedian do you play a comedy show
that's around the book
yeah essentially it'd just be beautiful
it would essentially just be no no i
would just go on the road and do
my show and then afterwards just to uh
signings and and then sort of go to the
bookstores around the country and
um i've i don't know i've never done one
you ever said the word [ __ ] in the
waterstones you could do
oh yeah that'd be happening yeah you've
seen it you've see you've seen the [ __ ]
they're getting watched
of course how are you doing it in there
you're walking around you know what i
mean
i well but i mean i i would love to i i
i would be thrilled to see what parts of
the book they would like me read them at
waterstones
uh if if if oh no i mean it will be
released in the uk
eventually but once it's i'm also
rewriting it at the moment yeah you
mentioned you making it making a few
changes here
yeah just um i wrote a chapter on well i
want to now write a chapter on mental
health because
in january i thought it was the [ __ ]
god of it i was like [ __ ]
you know it was one of those that
uttered arrogance of like oh look
look hi mental health is very very
important
for other people who have problems with
it and i support them from a distance
but i don't become perfect so
ah no self-reflection bye um
we just know that i've been helped
immensely thanks to
uh therapy and and upon self-reflection
and meditation i want to do a bit on
that
i also um just upon a further [ __ ]
reflection i didn't
there was a couple of chapters in there
where it was just the the ego was still
in there
and it wasn't an irony there wasn't
enough reflection in it and
and also there was a royal chapter on
you know america
and because i do love america for many
many reasons and i
dislike many many things about it but i
sort of wrote this chapter trying to
explain how difficult
that was but it was a i think it was
i didn't think i was being too gentle
because uh
my experience of america was as it was
as a successful
white man and upon us during lockdown
one of the things i really started
studying american history because i find
it fascinating and learning about the
country more and then seeing everything
that's happened especially this year
uh i think i was too [ __ ] gentle i
think
anything that was written at the
beginning of this year null and void
yeah like you can't expect and there's
something bizarre as well
you can create a youtube video i could
publish something now that we recorded
in january and just like
title it as like was recorded in january
and no one really gives a [ __ ]
right however if you write a book
there's something about it that's like
supposed to be evergreen and incarnate
you know
like it transcends time and space and
people presume i think it's
partly the medium it's so [ __ ]
bourgeois people just presume that it's
like
you've got the 20 20 vision literally
and um
i can imagine that if you had written
that it would have felt
like you kind of cemented something that
you probably didn't agree with
yes i like and i was so grateful too my
publishers they
instantly random house when i was like
i'd like to update it they were like
excuse me
yes i'm like hello i was wrong about a
bunch of things and they were like thank
god you said
how's it going to print because it's
good
uh they have been so understanding uh
uh with it because yeah i also have a
real problem with being um
proud of work that i've done like
um i can't accept them as stamps of
times of things like i watch old
material and i go i was wrong then and i
can't put myself in the position i was
like yes but you felt at the time and
things have changed and you've changed
so i don't watch any of my old shows
and they make me very uncomfortable um
you said that you've i think i've heard
you say before that you kind of watch
recent stuff to refine your
uh yeah yeah process but there's like
like maybe an 18-month window and like
anything before that is deleted
absolutely yeah it's dead i can't watch
myself [ __ ] uh if
something this is a [ __ ] thing to say
but sometimes when i watch some of my
[ __ ] old stand up i thought
just i'm like my fans are the dumbest
just sitting watching this [ __ ] [ __ ]
stand up this [ __ ] young cocky piece
of [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] and i'm like [ __ ] how
did people
ever fall for that you [ __ ] charlatan
isn't that the way that everything's
supposed to be though like i can't
bear to go back and listen to the first
hundred episodes
of this show i'm like oh my god what's
going on but the thing is if that's the
way that you look at stuff
you know that in 100 more episodes or in
three more years you're going to look at
the stuff that you've just done now
and think what a what an idiot how are
you
terrible it's always that that growth
mindset is always going to leave the
previous you in the dust
that is the implication of growth i
think i but but i also
yes but with with growth and with age
should come wisdom and if you apply
wisdom to your past
self you should be able to be like hey
yeah go away
that was me then right and i don't hate
that i'm different now and i prefer the
changes i've made now i like who i'm
about i don't hate that
but i said that's hopefully what the
wisdom of your speaks but i just don't
have it yet not yet maybe
maybe 50 or 60. so what's what's next
are you able to make plans for the
future at the moment so you've got a
couple of book chapters to write a
couple of book chapters
right and the second i get an internet
connection i will be uh
attempting to uh get onto twitch just
[ __ ] explore see what that is because
it's
i don't want to go with to any many
expectations i want to just see what it
is and see whether or not i'm good at it
um and then hopefully just tours man um
like
i mean we just don't we just don't know
anything at the moment it's i'm really
really enjoying now
because even though uh
gigs can be pulled at any [ __ ] moment
with a gig at the standard newcastle
pool last week because
just health and safety concerns um
that's the sort of world we live in now
uh i'm enjoying the time at home and i'm
actually really enjoying the time at
home now
uh now that i'm now that i'm friends
with my brain again
like it's it's a good time like um
enjoying i usually reconnect with
friends man because for so many years
touring and traveling and stuff i didn't
get to nurture any friendships if it was
very much i said to my friends i'm like
hey
these are the two weeks i'm back and i'm
literally to my two of my closest
friends the alleys
for years and years and they were such
good friends i was like whenever i'm
back from tour
do not [ __ ] invite me to your house
if you want to see me you'll come to
where i live
because i spend most of my time on the
road so when i'm home i want to be home
i thought i don't want to go to where
you live i don't want to [ __ ] meet
you come to me
which is a totalitarian nazi status to a
friendship
but one which i sort of had to do for
years and now
now i don't i get to be a i get to be a
better friend i get to be a better
person i'm a normal guy right i
i like this this is the thing i think a
lot of people don't see
in success like the price that you pay
to be at the absolute precipice of the
top of your particular field
is a lot of sacrifices that the person
who is
98 of the way to where you are
isn't because 98 of the effort is the
returns go like that everybody knows
there's like i don't know maybe
200 to 500 comedians on the planet that
are ever gonna have a netflix special
like within the next however long like
or maybe no maybe not even that maybe
hundreds hundreds like comedians like
okay so to get there
the difference between you and the next
guy has to be so so great
so that two percent is actually maybe
another double the workup
to just get that extra little bit in and
unfortunately that is the
sacrifices of 300-day
tours and you know playing i remember we
were talking he was saying it almost got
to the stage where you didn't feel like
a comedian anymore it was like a
performance and
time away from friends and like can you
deal with that suffering like do you
want that
as a an upcoming uh actor
comedian writer you know do you want to
be working to that kind of a schedule
with that kind of suffering with that
kind of sacrifice
because if you don't you're going to
outwork them i
and you've and unfortunately it almost
becomes like a battle of attrition like
we've realized that with the show i
think
i think i think it depends on the type
of success you want like if you want to
be
uh the the prodigy if you want to be
the first to do it or the youngest to do
it with the
quick for everything for a lot of things
uh
then yes it is um about that and it's
about that extra two percent
but so many of the
greatest comedians of all time and i
will i will even put this into most of
the other art forms as well and
a lot of jobs ah they
are the best not for how fast they did
it but for how consistently they do over
the years like bill barr
who's widely regarded now as one of the
correctest of all time and in my opinion
rightfully so
uh maddie's been different he's been
doing it for [ __ ] 30 years he's been
doing non-stop for three years and we
only just
i mean the he only really came into the
forefront in the past five years
right people where did he come from
would you he's always been there he's
always been there
25 years of hard regular graft where you
know he was
working and probably making a lot of the
um sacrifices i mean there's so many
brilliant comedians that only are being
recognized in their 50s you know tom
stead worked his ass off since he was 18
and there's now
i think i think sorry if you're watching
stead i think he's [ __ ] 50 now he's
nearly dead
uh he's getting the recognition um
now i think there's two ways to do it
and i went for the
speedy [ __ ] first one and thankfully
this year
forced me to slow down but um
i don't know i still think my [ __ ]
hunger is there i still as
as much as it's been nice to be a bit uh
docile
yeah i'm definitely i'm not [ __ ] done
so i feel like that as well
i think a lot of people might do too i
wonder how many of the listeners
can resonate with this the fact that it
does feel a little bit
like you've become domesticated
literally and mentally
that you can't i've been relatively low
energy
like relatively sort of low charisma
like who am i going to be big dick to
like myself on camera or the one guest
that i'm speaking to on the other side
of this
of the show like that's not going to
happen like the couple of friends that
i've
snuck in at like 4 p.m before the
restaurants close
i mean like you don't get to you don't
have that that gas
in you so much anymore and i think that
there's going to be a lot of people who
get re-released into the wild
who are going to have latent energy
that's going to catapult them through
and i think that's going to be really
exciting
i do too i think uh if
if and when the world goes back to
normal
um there'll be people who have a new
sense of
fire under their ass unfortunately
there's also plenty of people especially
with the arts who've just
i can't imagine i i think this pandemic
has probably caused
the loss of the greats of many many
[ __ ] things people who
in the arts who were able to do awards
because they were able to subsidize it
with a [ __ ] job but now
can't focus on their passion because
they're just trying to [ __ ] make ends
meet
i know so many good comedians who have
just gone
i'm not comedian anymore like i can't
there's no work and i
and i that'll go to over to art it'll go
over to you know
acting it will go to all this in fact
not even just the arts [ __ ] plumbers
technicians
programmers or maybe not they could do
from home athletes
athletes yeah i truly think
we've lost uh covert has caused the loss
of a generation of greats
and uh we don't know what the long-term
effects of
kovatar i think we're gonna have a
generation of kids
who were you know born for the first six
months so those crucial development
years where they were only going to see
both of their parents what are the
long-term effects of that the first six
months of your life
only two phases what a long time if any
um
but one of the other long-term effects
is you know
maybe they'll just be in 25 [ __ ]
years a bunch of time when
art sucks for a bit everyone's a plumber
uh football's just a little bit shiter
we're like [ __ ]
i have to say i really enjoy the
football without the fan noise
i just think because there's a dj have
you seen this
like the fake the fake noise and the
pressure and how good are those [ __ ]
d
like sometimes they get it wrong it's
very funny when they get it wrong
like it's they're like oh no it's mine
but fans did that as well that was you
know the amount of times i thought much
you'd go hey
oh [ __ ] uh so two questions
first one um if someone's had some
challenges with their relationship
during covid what would you say
any any bits of advice of how they might
be able to deal with it a little bit
better
oh man i mean here's one of the stances
i still stand by
thoroughly chicks or is if your
relationship quite requires any [ __ ]
effort
even during a pandemic man i me and my
girlfriend didn't follow once and then
again don't be wrong i know there's
going to be [ __ ] people who've been
married for 25 years
and they're going to be like just still
in the [ __ ] honeywell phase just wait
you're still in the honeymoon phase
maybe or maybe i didn't fall in love
with a [ __ ]
um who knows we'll never know we'll know
in 25 years now
um no i i had no advice i'd like because
i'm
i'm in a shitty not ashamed i'm in a
really good position where
i didn't have to work at my
non-representative position
and and also yeah i i thoroughly
recommend people watch
uh jigsaw during quality because where
can they get that now
that's that's quite a long time it's
been on two years uh
yeah i think i think they i think they
have it forever
is it i don't know it's generally not
sure [ __ ] me i don't know what i mean
where else would it go
well i don't know i don't know how long
had it i don't know how long it's up
there
uh fun thing lessons from 2020 what's
going to be the biggest lesson that you
take away from 2020
uh and
had i heard myself say this in january i
would have
knocked myself out but uh just
[ __ ] take better care of yourself
take responsibility for
uh your physical health take
responsibility for your mental health
and and
i like like this year it
took a real [ __ ] knock to the
confidence but i'm glad
that you know that i did have the the
courage and the strength to go to
therapy
to seek help that you know i did stick
to you know meditation and
you know learning about myself and just
deciding to go [ __ ] i need to slow down
like last year was really hard and
admitting that i was having a hard time
which is hard to do because
we're all so reluctant to admit we're
having a hard time because everyone's
having a hard time so you don't want to
admit it so you go oh i know
all these other people in a worse
position so how dare i think i'm in a
bad position
and that's not true for anyone that's
not how the world works and if you think
that way get out of your [ __ ] head
you're allowed to be as miserable as you
want to be
uh but do what you can to to not feel
that way
we all deserve to be happy i love it man
it's an oddly
uh an oddly balanced and positive way
for us to finish one of these
it's usually berating people that we
don't like well wait wait
wait until like wait let's get let's get
back in a year's time would like
comedies back and i'll be like listen
you're [ __ ] i'm back i'm confident
again
you're all [ __ ] [ __ ] i said last
year
he was in all right tell you what it
turns out you shouldn't love yourself
you should just [ __ ] love me
oh man so book out next year next year
it's twitch have you got twitch yet uh i
am yes uh it's
dinosaurs i think uh underscores
it's not a common name you'll find me
but i don't have any followers on it yet
and the account's barely set up because
once again it's always internet
connection in the world still
where else instagram instagram and also
watch enough watch jigsaw yeah go on
dart go on netflix to watch uh dark and
jigsaw and also if you follow
go my website dinosloss.com we're adding
two dates
we're not tour dates we're adding dates
all the time we'll be doing sports in
random places over the next couple of
months and
uh just there really come come see me
while i'm humble again
what a unique opportunity i know i get
small
small bits there's people watching this
being like i can't believe he thinks he
was humble
and thank you so much as always i
shouldn't have done that
illegal absolutely
you